Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck check off
a newlywed Milestone what can I tell you
we're just having a good time the singer
taking fans inside their holidays at
home including how their kids have come
together as a blended family after mom
and dad tied the knot
somebody's getting married in Jen's
latest on the JLo newsletter the triple
threat gushes over their first Christmas
together as Mr and Mrs Affleck yeah
tinsel anyone JLo poses with the
couple's decked out Christmas tree and
look closely at her stunning Gucci gown
because there's some special symbolism
there people I'm ready I'm excited about
it as Jen explains in the newsletter
2022's holiday theme is hummingbirds she
thinks of them as little good luck
charms and this designer dress in a
hummingbird color scheme was perfect for
the fam's Christmas party Gucci's been
such a huge part of my life and in other
snaps a glimpse of the couple's cozy
Vibes at home I like those Christmas
sweaters baby but when it comes to
staying warm JLo's go-to is personal I
want to give it away but it has a very
good ending Jen explains she loves a
wool blanket calling them Chic and a
throwback to her roots in the Bronx a
time when her family couldn't afford
much so she used the same wool blanket
for most of her early years
she adds quote sometimes Ben and the
kids make fun of me because I like the
Itchy feeling of wool against my skin
but it reminds me of my childhood my
areas of extra cheese is the kids are
best it's not homework but hey at least
those little ones helped make Christmas
a family affair a source tells E.T the
kids are doing great and get along
effortlessly quote they all really have
respect for each other Jennifer's
relationship with Ben's kids is natural
and same goes for Ben's bond with
Jennifer's kids
yeah
[Music]
and Jen's already let it be known her
wish list looked a little different this
year
and what do you want this year for
Christmas
um
I have everything I want
but in the spirit of giving better for
2.0 grabbed the mic at their holiday
party earlier this month
[Music]
singing A Chorus or two for family and
friends
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
for Ben Jen and everyone following their
love story guess you could say it's
without a doubt
love Christmas